c'est une route déserte
jonchée d'épaves
qui mène la ville de choï
[Musique]
pour échapper aux frappes et russe ils
sont des milliers ici à habiter sous
terre
de nice nos guides à travers 7 avril
[Musique]
tous ces gens ont fui leur maison ils
vivent les uns sur les autres taillée
par la peur et la fin
épuisés ou malades
dans ce refuge
beaucoup d'enfants
je te lis mais 700
beaucoup de vieillards aussi
aux trop faible trop port pour partir
loin
voilà six semaines qu'il dit entre
boutiques
[Musique]
partout dans l'ukraine en guerre des
bénévoles veillent sur eux
l'auteur a dit m habiter
c'est un dédale de pièces
400 personnes s'y entassent
et à l'extérieur
pourquoi
ai-je martine aubry
de nice travaille dans une usine de
bouteilles fermé à cause des combats
seize membres de sa famille se partagent
cette pièce
quant à voyages
chocolatier journée kg j
à la sortie de la ville après de durs
combats
les soldats d'ukrainiens ont repris un
peu de terrain
d'après eux c'est une bombe riche de 500
kg qui a creusé ce cratère
tous les jours ou presque à l'hôpital
arrive les blessés de la commune
[Musique]
interdiction de filmer l'extérieur du
bâtiment le personnel a peur qu'ils
soient localisés et bombarder les russes
n'épargnant pas écoles les hôpitaux
[Musique]
à tchoyi ve six civils ont déjà été
tuées et plus d'une centaine blessées
la maire de la ville est débordée elle
trouve un temps pour nous recevoir mais
très vite
il faut évacuer
les frappeurs russes ont repris
et les bâtiments administratifs sont
régulièrement ciblée
à l'inami naïve à des journées très
chargées
à chaque nouvelle alerte les rues achève
de s'éviter
dans son abri le petit platon lui
s'ennuie
alors il dessine tout ce qu'il a dans la
tête
il est temps pour nous de quitter le
refuge
avant de partir pelatan a tenu à nous
laisser un souvenir
un cadeau bien du long